notice it's a little delayed
hey everybody Welcome to today's R
Studio Enterprise Community Meetup
I'm joined here by Tom and we're just
chatting for a second to see if the
LinkedIn stream is working as well
how are you doing today Tom
I'm doing great happy Tuesday it's
always a good day of the week
awesome let me go over
to LinkedIn and see if we cool and see
ourselves
I'll just mention that for today's
slides the link will be at the bottom of
every slide so you can always copy it
from there if you come in later
um as well as we're going to be screen
sharing and using Multiplex for the
first time today which will allow us to
like actually change the slide on other
people's computers which is kind of neat
so we'll try that out
awesome well look at that it is working
on LinkedIn so hi friends thank you so
much for joining today welcome to the
rstudio Enterprise Community Meetup
I'm Rachel and I've met so many of you
already so thank you for joining back
today I'm calling in from Boston today
and we are streaming out to LinkedIn and
YouTube right now so if you've just
joined now feel free to say hi through
the chat maybe where you're calling in
from so excited to have you here for our
third quarto Meetup in the past few
months
if you missed the past two and welcome
to quarto workshop and building a Blog
with Cordo I'll be sure I'll be sure to
share those in the chat as well
but today we are joined by my friend
here at rstudio Tom mock who is going to
teach us about building beautiful
reports and presentations with Cordo
if this is your first time joining one
of these sessions this is a friendly and
open Meetup environment for teams to
share use cases teach lessons learned
and just meet each other and ask
questions
together we're all dedicated to making
this an inclusive and open environment
for everybody no matter your experience
industry or background
so I will also share a link in the chat
where you can find out about other
upcoming events too as we have these
meetups every Tuesday at 12 eastern time
we also have a data science hangout
every Thursday at 12 eastern time and
would love to see you at those too
I just want to say during the event
today you are able to ask questions
on the platform that you're watching
from and it will pull together here for
us or also anonymously
through slido and we'll share that link
in just a second here and pull it up on
the screen
but thank you again so much for joining
us here today I'm so excited to have you
with us here too Tom and I will turn it
over to you
awesome thanks so much for hosting
Rachel and for all your help in getting
this stuff off the ground
um we're gonna be talking about
beautiful reports and presentations with
Porto uh it feels a little bit meta in
the sense that like you're presenting
about quarto with quarto on Cordo kind
of like all the things wrapping up
together
and something we're trying out today and
I think one of the benefits of using a
format like Cordo or reveal.js through
Cordo is that uh like for now Rachel's
actually sharing her screen so I'm able
to actually advance and modify slides on
her computer just by changing them on
mine so you can imagine a situation kind
of like today where maybe my computer's
acting a little funky and I'm actually
allowing my colleague to screen share or
to work you know remotely on their own
computer or like for y'all if you access
the slides
from the URL at the bottom of the screen
I can actually advance and kind of
display the slides as you're progressing
through them whether in a teaching
setting or in kind of this webinar style
setting
so we're going to get kicked off and I
will run with it
so first off I just want to mention that
you know we talk about this pretty
frequently but uh Cordo and our studio
have very deep integration together so
you have What's called the visual editor
so this is just a screenshot of a few
different things from the visual editor
mode in our studio
you can use this to do word processing
and kind of modification of quarto
documents including presentations and
there's lots of helpers there for
inserting divs and spans some things
we'll be talking about as well as things
like tables Graphics links code chunks
lots of help in terms of making you more
productive
one of the benefits that Cordo provides
is that the visual editor mode is
available for really all the different
formats so again whether you're writing
a presentation or a report or something
else those can all be edited in in
visual editor mode
the first thing we're going to talk
about for today and we've got a lot of
kind of content to cover so I'm trying
to provide a lot of overview and kind of
exciting broad overview of things that
are available in quarto so first off we
have static documents or essentially
reports that you're writing I'd like to
think of these as like your your daily
driver you know you can use it for basic
kind of exploratory work but it's
powerful enough to also present uh and
kind of display results to your
colleagues uh even publish to a journal
or as the final output for your team to
share with uh leadership or other
stakeholders
I think Cordo and static documents are
most powerful when they're combining
this idea of like written thoughts and
observations like the human and the loop
in terms of I'm adding context and
adding pros and text about what I'm
working on but I'm also including the
source code there so I can be
reproducible in creating my journal
article or creating my documentation or
creating my report I'm putting together
so in that Spirit of kind of combining
source code with uh with the report
they're actually generating we're going
to kick off by talking about parameters
and parameterized quarter reporting
you may have used these in our markdown
or maybe you never use parameters in our
markdown before but parameters work
inside Cordo as a way to create
different variations of the same
document by changing out small
components
most commonly you see examples of this
like I want to create a report for this
specific region so like for today's tidy
Tuesday data it's you know 50 different
states and all the different things that
are available within those and you can
imagine I want to generate a report for
Texas as well as
Massachusetts or New York or California
like all these different states that I
want to create separate reports for
but it could also be covering a specific
time period so if you're doing like a
Time series analysis maybe you want to
report over the you know the past year
but maybe someone asks you say okay well
I just need the data for the past month
rather than restarting that report from
scratch you could actually use
parameters to regenerate that with just
changing out the date
or kind of the last example just
re-running a single analysis multiple
times and changing components so maybe
you're doing machine learning with Heidi
models and you're switching out the
different engines that are available uh
for that model so you can still do like
a random Forest but change it out from
Ranger to the random forest model to a
spark model for example
and we'll walk through a few of these
different examples
there's two ways of actually defining
parameters uh in Python if you're using
that with quarto we use what's called
paper mill style which is a way of again
providing parameters and generating many
reports from one set of source code
in this situation uh the tags are
actually generated
um within the code chunk so you use the
Hash Pipe syntax then you define tags
and then you have like a vector of
parameters that you're creating
so in this case we have Alpha and ratio
that are being defined as both being 0.1
these can be accessed later on in the
document by name so they're not
um they're really kind of like first
class objects in the situation of like
you can't name something else alpha or
ratio those are going to be the actual
um in kind of memory object that you're
using in Python
in r or using the Knitter engine uh
we'll Define them in the yaml so you'll
use what are called the params key and
then you can define specific parameters
there again like Alpha and ratio and
giving specific values whether that's
numeric or text or other strings
these are accessed in source code using
the params dollar sign syntax so you'll
actually extract something like Alpha
from the params environment
in this situation you could actually
have Alpha being in the um in memory as
an object and then params dollar sign
Alpha that you can access separately but
generally you don't really want to name
them exactly the same to avoid kind of
namespace collisions
the last option here is you can actually
Define and modify parameters from your
command line interface to Cordo or via
the terminal so if you call quarter
render on a specific document you can
modify the parameters with the dash p
and then Define the new parameter you
want to change so if I wanted to change
Alpha to 0.2 and ratio to 0.3 I could
have multiple calls with uh Dash p and
then Alpha equals 0.2 and Dash p ratio
equals 0.3
and again so regardless of kind of how
you're building out your document what
language you're using there's there's
these ways to approach it and modify the
document so that when you're generating
it you can get multiple reports from the
same set of source code
now that we've kind of talked a little
bit about what parameters kind of how
they're defined let's actually show a
little bit of how those could be used
so I have this example of a pretty
simple report in this case we're using
the Palmer Penguins data set and we're
generating out a report that looks
something like this on the right
just says you know when it was published
and it's got data about this set of
penguins and and which ones are
classified as this specific species
at the top left this slide on line five
of the yaml it says params equals
species equals to adeli so that's the
default in terms of if we render this
document as is it's actually going to
always generate a report for how to
light Penguins you know it's not
changing itself unless we say we're
going to change it but we can access
that parameter with params dollar sign
species in a couple different locations
so we can use it in our filter step on
line eight of the first code chunk and
we can also use it in inline code with
the backtick r param dollar sign species
and again report on it both in inline
code as well as in our overall code
chunk
but the big takeaway being we could
actually change out that parameter to a
different species and actually get a
whole new report from the same uh same
quarto document
so if we were to do this via the CLI we
might do something like quarter render
that report or quarter render that
report as say like an IPython notebook
if we're doing it from Jupiter uh in
that situation and then we could define
specific parameters with the dash p and
change species to Gen 2 and get this Gen
2 dollars report out as opposed to a
different name so we can actually say
the output is going to be a new report
name because we don't want to overwrite
the existing adelai report that we've
generated
so this is fine in terms of like I can
render it with the CLI I can modify that
parameter on the Fly
um but maybe I don't want to use the
command line interface to do this
rendering
I could also do it with something like
pure R code so it might have a render
function I write in this case I'm using
the r package Cordo and quarto
underscore render this allows me to take
in an existing report
penguinreport.qmd modify the parameters
According to which species we're
applying and then name the report
according to again which which species
we're using
so here we can find all the unique
species across this whole data set walk
across them or regenerate the report
with the per our package and render that
on each of the three penguin species
this will create something like the
Adelaide report the chin strap report
and the Gen 2 report all of which have
slightly different parameters that have
been modified and now we have three
different versions of the report by
species as opposed to having to rewrite
the entire report from scratch or copy
paste code across
so using parameterized reports like this
even if you're doing it for you know
really sophisticated uh nice looking
reports that you're building is one of
the powers and kind of superpowers of
using code and using things like quarto
to generate out those documents
another example that might be more
applicable to folks coming from like the
machine learning aspect is maybe you
have a report and uh you know we'll just
say that we're adapting it from some
tidy model stocks in this case we're
using our parameter of a specific engine
so the default is using the ranger
engine and we're using that for a random
forest model
but we could also change out that engine
to any other engines that um the Tidy
models ecosystem can accept
so we can take that same tidy models
example report use the random Forest
engine or the ranger engine or Spark
engine and again all you know reusing
most of the source code but just
changing out that engine and running it
in a slightly different context
if we do this we can actually generate
out two sets of kind of predictions or
two sets of metrics from this report
so you know these really don't look any
different but just that we have run the
report twice and if you look at some of
the very small value changes we can
actually see that the values did change
so like on line 9 on both sides we have
a prediction of 5.25 versus 5.32 and the
accuracy or the rmse and some other
metrics are actually slightly better
when we use the ranger engine for this
so regardless in terms of like whether
you're trying to regenerate a new report
that you're actually using to tell a
story or if you're doing exploratory
analysis and doing like different models
or different engines that you're trying
to run you can use parameters to modify
and decrease the amount of code that you
have to write for doing those steps
so while I think parameter is really
exciting and I wanted to kick off with
that as like there's a benefit to using
Code one of the other benefits that
Porto provides is you know regardless of
if you're using lots of code or changing
it out or reusing it you might actually
want to generate multiple different
types of outputs so maybe you're
creating a PDF document a Word document
and an HTML report you know those are
three different ecosystems that all take
quite different
um kind of code behind the scenes
Cordo as much as possible tries to make
that code easy to use in terms of using
the same syntax across all of them and
unifying the work that you're doing
across different output formats
so let's say we have this report I have
a dog named Howard who's a Boston
Terrier so I took an example from
Wikipedia there's this article about
Boston Interiors I copied it over and
converted it to a a Cordo document
so with this unified syntax I could do
something like quarter render that
document to HTML or to PDF
now I haven't optimized this document
only for HTML meaning I haven't written
a bunch of CSS and I haven't optimized
this document only for PDF meaning I
haven't written a lot of latex or really
any latex I've only used quarto style
Syntax for this or kind of unified
syntax that works across formats
when I generate this report out I get
something that looks like this where I
have a nice looking article I've got an
image in the gutter I've got hoverable
citations I've got a floating table of
contents you get all the power of what
HTML can provide for a nice you know
report or document you're creating
but without changing that document and
literally just saying render to PDF I
also get a really nice looking PDF
document that's pagenated and has you
know whatever the limitations are PDF
like doing that
in terms of its still reports on the
history it still has citations and
images in the sidebar or the margin but
I haven't necessarily had to optimize
only for HTML or only for PDF I was
actually able to use cordo's unified
syntax across both very different uh
kind of outputs that I'm creating
so we're going to dive in a little bit
to what the syntax is how you can use it
to kind of be safe as to the different
type of outputs you're creating and walk
across some of that
and what I mean by this unified syntax
is that Cordo makes heavy use of what
are called fence divs and bracketed
spans
so here on this page we have fence divs
we have three colons that start the
fence and three colons that end the
fence so you can imagine that when
you're writing these you always need to
have kind of a front and a start or the
enclosing of some content within those
once we've used three colons to indicate
the start and the end we can then apply
a specific class or specific name of the
div that we're applying so it might be
something like dot class or dot panel
tab set or or whatever it is just some
name within those curly brackets that
are after the fence div
and then anything within the start and
end of that fence div will be modified
so everything inside that will be
affected in some way or you can alter it
in a useful way moving forward
this structure again starts and ends
with an equal number of colons there's
always a minimum of three but they can
be however many colons you want as long
as it's three or more and you match the
start to the end you're going to add
those curly brackets after uh the three
colons and this indicates the start and
the end as well as the class so again
like dot class or sometimes it doesn't
require that dot and it might be
something like word one dash word two or
sometimes dot dash class
overall just that when you see this
syntax inside maybe quarter
documentation or in other examples uh
making you aware of what those mean
one example of how to do this is we can
actually do figure layout of different
images and include like alt text with
them and other things so we'll have
three colons curly bracket layout number
of columns equals to two
and this will create a two column layout
and as long as you have two images it'll
put one on the left one on the right and
then it'll start over and if you added
more images it would stack them always
adding up to two columns
you can modify this and have number of
rows or number of columns be larger but
overall just showing that this type of
syntax again can apply to word or to PDF
or to HTML it's basically allowing you
to be safe across different types of
output formats
another example of how to use this is
something like dot panel Dash tab set
now this one is very specific to HTML
but I just want to show off kind of some
of the things you can do with this some
of it can be used only for protecting
yourself against different output
formats and other times it can just be
useful in terms of providing cool things
that HTML can do
so a DOT panel Dash tab set allows you
to create little tabs that you can step
through and kind of organize your code
in that way
after you create the fence div again
with three colons to start three colons
to end and then your class of dot panel
Dash tab set you'll define specific tabs
by level two headers so you know two
pound signs element one that'll be your
first tab two pound signs element two
that'll be your second Tab and then you
can have content within each of them
what this looks like in practice is you
might actually have code and output so
if I were to click on code first it'll
just show off the code that is
unevaluated but if Rachel were to click
on output it would actually show the
output there on her screen
so now she can actually click through
and see you know have some type of
interactivity or have some type of
interaction with the document in
addition to me actually having to step
through all of it
again this is limited to HTML output
because there's that true interactivity
but just showing that
um these these fence divs are not just
for kind of doing some of the basics but
allow you to do more across all the
different HTML formats as well
if I wanted to create or show how that
was actually uh shown on the page
um that dot panel tab set and then I
have a level two header code I have some
you know R code that I'm putting in
there I have another level two header
called output and that one is actually
going to eval equals true basically show
the output but Echo equals false and not
show
um the source code itself
this is just a basic example but you can
imagine that you could have again these
multiple tab sets that you're using with
fence divs allowing the user to explore
your document and interact more with it
as they're reading through walking
through the document
the other item that allows you to again
either protect yourself against
different formats you're creating for or
just do cool things are what are called
bracketed spans
we have a sentence on this page that is
missing some words this is a magic text
basically text that shows up after the
fact when I click next on my side of the
screen
we can do this again with what is called
a bracketed span so we do square
brackets around specific text in this
case magic text for the previous example
we're showing and then just like with
our fence divs we apply a specific class
to that text
the main difference between these two is
that offensive will apply to like an
entire paragraph or collection of text
and a bracketed span could be applied to
a single word or single words within an
overall sentence so you can imagine you
know applying to the whole paragraph
versus small components of that again to
you know help tell your story or
indicate something on the page
here I'm using a DOT fragment class
which is specific to presentations but
this lets you actually delay the
presentation and delay the specific word
to show up later as you're moving
through that slide deck
so overall you know bracketed spans can
do a lot but just showing one example
here quickly inside the presentation
format
the structure would be something like
this you're going to surround specific
texts that you want to affect or the
specific object you want to affect with
square brackets around it and again you
have a left and a right square bracket
indicating a start and an end of what's
being modified
once that is written out you're going to
add curly brackets to indicate the start
and end of the specific class so
something like Curly bracket dot class
or dot fragment and then closing it off
with another curly bracket so that it
can be fully interpreted
and again this just allows you to modify
specific components of the text or style
your document
um in in specific ways
one example it's a slight modification
of this and one that we use in that
report about Boston Terriers is we
actually create inline footnotes so
something like some inline text with a
kind of tilde and then the square
bracket footnote or this uh up up Arrow
kind of symbol
this allows us to add a footnote or kind
of this like endnote to a specific word
so in the document it'll show this as
like a hyperlink back to the footnote or
the endnote but also allow you to inject
a lot of text about that overall so it
could be kind of like a citation or just
an aside or a comment that you're making
that you don't want to display all the
time
in HTML these can be hoverable in terms
of in an HTML document I can actually
hover over those footnotes and see them
displayed kind of as an overlay in the
document in a PDF they don't necessarily
have the ability to render that
additional JavaScript or css so they're
just linked to the footnote or the
endnote at the end of the page or at the
end of the document
and what this looks like in practice is
I might have a sentence like for example
did you know that Howard is a dog and
then adding a specific footnote
specifically he is a Boston Terrier
although sometimes he acts like a cat
so by providing that footnote you know
that specifically all the way through
cat that whole section is hidden on the
page but added as this footnote
providing an additional context about
the sentence as we're walking through it
so if you're using this for kind of
scientific documentation or just kind of
a sides you're making a useful thing to
add to your documents
the unified syntax can also do more
complex things in terms of we move back
to fence divs we can overall structure
our document so here from that actual
article I showed I have a mixing of
images aligning those with text and
paragraphs and putting it together
something like this
uh so for here I've applied a layout
class and I have the image as 30 of the
width of the page and then layout equals
to 70 for paragraph one and then below
that uh a hundred indicating that
paragraph two will take up the remaining
uh width of the page below the other two
and again regardless of the output
format PDF or word or HTML I can
structure and kind of typeset my
document using this type of syntax
I could also move one of those images
into the margin so you know I had the
small boss interior that was on the
right side of the screen I have a
traditional kind of hyperlink to an
image on this page and then
um I have a specific class on that
called a DOT column Dash margin and that
actually takes the image and throws it
into the margin of the overall document
while the rest of the body continues on
and then as we talked about just
previously add things like footnotes so
information about where did I get this
detail the average life of a Boston
Terrier is around 11 to 13 years this
was a retrieved from the Boston Terrier
Club of America and providing additional
context about that citation or around
that detail that we're adding
so this unified syntax again while I
think that writing for HTML is some of
the most powerful way you can actually
do this in certain situations you have
to write to PDF or you want to write a
PDF or to word docs so you can
collaborate on them in a different way
you can use this unified syntax across
different output formats with a quarter
report you're putting together
again while I think that um Cordo
reports you know in terms of making them
look beautiful and and typesetting them
is very useful ultimately a different
value that quarter provides is that it
can also add code in both the display of
that code The Hiding of that code or you
know just the output of that code itself
as a graphic as a table or as raw text
so in your document you might have
something like this where you have an
HTML document you're creating and you
want to have you know the code not be
shown maybe you're generating a report
that's going up to leadership they don't
necessarily want to read our code or
python code they just want to see the
final report they don't necessarily care
how you got there maybe they just want
to see the details
so in this case you can still keep the
source code so you can keep your dot qmd
that has all the source code the links
out to the data basically how you got
there but when you generate out your
report it doesn't show any of the code
it just shows the output and the
commentary that you've added to it
you can still turn on code individually
so let's say you turned on Echo equals
false at the top and the yaml at the
code chunk level you can actually add
and say like for this one code chunk I
want it to be Echo equals true so
regardless of what the yaml says turn
Echo and actually show the code for this
specific document
you can also rather than hide all the
code and make it where no one can see it
is you can do what's called code folding
and in this case you'll have code
folding that you can hide temporarily in
terms of it'll fold all the code behind
a little menu bar that you can click on
and that little menu bar will be called
hidden code so you can click on each
individual code chunk and display it and
then collapse it as you move forward
and again this could be turned on at the
specific code chunk level where I could
have code folding turned on for one code
chunk so even if I was hiding all the
rest of it for one that might be really
important I can still say hey this one
allows you to toggle the code showing on
or off again
foreign
going a bit further you know maybe we
want to show the code maybe you don't
want to show the code we can also use
what are called code dash tools so in
your format you might have format equals
HTML or PDF code tools equals true gives
us this little overlay where the user
can make all of the decisions so at the
very top of the document they can have
this little drop down and they can you
know hide all the code or show all the
code or in some situations even view the
source document so you can embed all of
the source code into the document and
when you click on it that allows you to
show all the source code before the
results were generated or link out to an
external Repository
again this just allows you to make those
decisions as you're using it for
reporting but you can choose how much of
the code or how much of the contacts you
want to display for your users
if we wanted to show The Source in terms
of like literally embed the source code
into the document you could use code
tools equals Source equals true toggle
equals false and no caption and this
will allow you to see the source code
but there all the code is also displayed
in the document and you're not trying to
hide it you're just trying to also embed
all that source code so that users can
see it or you as you're automating that
report can also see how the the document
was generated and if anything has
changed over time
overall when you display or look at the
source code it might look something like
this where you have an overlay that pops
up displaying what was all the source
code that you used literally the
markdown as well as the code chunks and
all the options of it so again very
useful for kind of checking that your
source code is actually valid for what
your expectations are
for other situations where you don't
necessarily want to embed all the source
code into the document or in some
situation where you really don't want to
show the code itself you want to have it
in like a private GitHub repository or
maybe it's just really long and you
don't want to embed all of that because
the user experience is not ideal
you could actually use code Tools Plus
source and indicate an external
repository so here we're linking out to
quarto dash Dev and linking out to a
specific markdown file that displays the
source code for that specific page so
they can actually go and look at it on a
first class you know version control
system as opposed to embedding it into
the document itself
but again you get to make that decision
in terms of displaying the code hiding
the code embedding the source code all
this different things you can do for
your users experience
we can then move on to things like
making the overall document look a bit
better so maybe you do want to show the
code but you have like a dark theme or
you have a specific style that you want
to apply to the code
so by default your code might look
something like this where it's
highlighting things like Library D plier
in your group by and other function
calls are highlighted in blue your
arguments are in green and it's doing
some highlighting of specific components
but it's really white on white with this
background
there's a lot of highlighting options
that I've included in a link at the full
highlighting options but you can modify
this throughout your document
so for our different themes let's say
we're using an HTML report we can stick
with highlight style equals Arrow which
will look something like this where you
have blue for function calls you can
have logical statements that are a
little bit lighter blue numerics are in
red and it allows you to kind of read
the source code a bit easier as opposed
to them all being one color all being
black or gray or something
but again what if you made this into
like a dark mode
so here we've modified the yaml header
to have the same highlight style of
Arrow which is the one we're trying to
use for accessibility reasons for um
contrast and other things but then we
have the ability to toggle on and off a
light mode in a dark mode
so in Cordo if you use a theme equals
light and theme equals dark and change
those out you can actually have a
toggleable option to make a switch from
light mode into dark mode
now this again will modify how the code
itself looks on the page because your
background is black
so you can use a highlight style like
arrow that works for both light and dark
and it will actually modify the
background color of the source code to
also match the light or the Dark theme
so again by changing out some of the
styling you can make your overall
document look the same or have the same
kind of theming or consistency As you
move across it
so while you know changing code itself
is kind of cool overall you're probably
a bit more interested in what you know
what else you can do with that code
so in R there's a package called downlit
and this not only provides like syntax
highlighting but also links out to
specific source code
so if you're using download and actually
evaluating code this will actually allow
you to click on the functions in the
chunk uh chunk output and it'll actually
link out to the documentation for that
so you imagine someone's like oh I saw
this cool package called per and it's
got this function called walk that Tom
was talking about in the presentation
you can actually click on my source code
and click on per walk and it will take
you to the documentation for per walk so
you can read a bit more about that
function
so download again will provide this
linking of the r code to external
documentation so that when people find
something they've never used before they
can actually move forward into the
documentation and have a lot of power
there to learn on the Fly
so while code is cool ultimately I think
that you want to do something like the
overall Aesthetics you have Howard here
and his you know finest Garb he wants to
look good for the presentation you also
want your report or your presentation to
look nice for your users or for your uh
your kind of stakeholders
so for HTML documents out of the box
Cordo is styled with something called
bootstrap 5. this is a CSS framework for
websites and version five is one of the
latest versions its overall applies a
lot of different theming to the overall
document
so Porto comes pre-installed with 25
different themes allowing you to set the
Aesthetics or the appearance of the
overall document and you can use them in
one or two lines of code
so in your yaml header you might Define
a format equals HTML and the theme as
something like litera that is a nice
minimal theme that really makes the
information pop as opposed to trying to
make a really fancy background or
something
but there's lots of different themes
that you can customize and go further
maybe you want to start from the litera
theme but further customize it with a
DOT scss file that's modifying the
structure or the appearance of the
document beyond the defaults that are
applied with the litera theme so you're
not stuck with it you can continue to
customize it with either CSS files or
scss files in this case if you're using
the theme output
boots watch themes are you know there's
many of them again I mentioned 25 I just
have a small selection of six here on
the page so again these are going to
change all the different elements
typefaces menu bars nav bars the overall
kind of weight of different fonts and
then colors of both the background the
foreground and buttons so when you're
creating these HTML documents this again
allows you to create nice looking
documents and not having to change all
the specific components yourself but
using these pre-built themes that look
really nice out of the box
foreign
when I gave some initial overview talk
about
um kind of reporting or in our first
Workshop we did there's a lot of people
asking about PDFs you know obviously I
think HTML is one of the best formats
and you can do the most with it but in
certain situations uh like a journal
article they want to get a latex file or
they want to get a PDF or in some
organizations just they want PDFs
because they're emailing them around or
doing things like that
so quarto can accept what are called
templates that allow you to style or
kind of take it as a default structure
with DOT Tech files so if you have those
laying around or modify them you can
further customize and optimize for PDF
if that's the route you want to go
there are there's also support for kind
of first class Journal articles from
Cordo so actually taking a document not
having to go and do write all this latex
code that you're customizing it with but
just using one of the quarto journal
formats and Publishing it out to
specific kind of
specific publication that you want to go
to like the ACM or the Journal of
statistical science or something like
that and you can end up with a report
that looks really really nice where this
journal of statistical software uh where
again you're not having to write all of
the custom latex to make the PDF look
like this but rather making use of
Porto's built in kind of chordo journals
formats that are available and just
writing things like what is the abstract
what is the title what are the authors
and their affiliations and it will take
that and build it into the document to
actually provide a useful output or what
the journal statistical software is
expecting when you actually deliver the
article to them
again quarto wants to support this idea
of reproducible science you know whether
that's science in an organization and
you're creating kind of static PDFs or
HTML documents or actually publishing in
Academia to to journals or two specific
journals in some cases
I want to say there's like 10 or 12
journals that are supported as of today
but we're also taking kind of feedback
from the community as to what other
journals are needed in working with
specific groups to to get those built
out
I also want to call out a nice project
from the nfms open science team so they
put together a quarto extension called
quarto title Pages the tech templates
were written by Eli Holmes in the Lua
filter they kind of makes it available
to Porto was written by Mikhail
and they have reports that look
something like this so yes this is not
necessarily like a journal article this
is more of like a professional PDF
report that you might use in a business
setting allow you to put your company
logo and stylize the report in a
specific way while also adding subtitles
and authors and other things to the
document something you could deliver in
like a Consulting setting or in a
business setting
there are additional ones but mostly
this is focused on improving the title
page which is a big deal in some of the
PDFs and making those look really really
nice as the default
so just wanted to call out some great
work that they've already done and
linking out to their repository that
talks more about that
so we've talked a lot and kind of gone
through a lot of different things with
reports in terms of HTML reports theming
them including code PDF reports and
articles and how you can modify those I
want to spend the last kind of section
of today talking about presentations
again I'm using quarto to write the
presentation today about Porto so I
really believe in the tool and its
ability to help you tell stories
there's a lot of supported output types
and I'll just call out three specific
ones reveal JS which is an HTML format
that's what I'm using today it has the
most power and you can use all of kind
of HTML and CSS and even some JavaScript
to do a lot with your presentation
but there's also support for things like
PowerPoint if you need to work in an
office setting or Microsoft Office kind
of Suite or if you want really prefer
working with like latex or PDF you can
also use the Beamer format to work with
that structure
so regardless of kind of which format
you're going to do I'm going to focus on
initially things that are cross format
and then talk about some things that are
specific to reveal.js that are really
powerful and exciting in my mind
I also want to call out again two other
community resources that I'm linked to
here on the slides so Emil wrote this
kind of slidecraft 101 and we'll talk
about that at the end of the
presentation about colors and fonts and
using them in quarto and then Megan put
together this nice overview of
customizing quarto slides and adding
little section headings that say like
you know rather than just being 37 of 58
slides through which section are we on
and what's going on in that page
foreign
for the things that are shared across
the different formats so again latex or
HTML or PowerPoint there's many
different things that are shared across
that so you can use what are called
incremental reveal or incremental lists
that allow you to display specific list
elements one by one you can control the
column layout the title The subtitle the
author the you know the kind of title
page of your document you can control
the headings as well as you're using
Code so you're able to display that code
hide that code and actually generate
things like tables graphics and text as
the output of your code that you're
generating from your quarto presentation
the first thing to remember is you know
for creating slides it could be as
simple as this uh in the yaml header
Define a specific format so I'm using
reveal.js but that could be PowerPoint X
or
um or Beamer and then each of your
additional slides will be indicated with
a level one or a level two header and
that's what indicates a new slide so
slide one is a level two header slide
one uh two more pound signs slide two
and that'll be slide two
and this allows you to structure your
document in a way that you can read the
source code but the actual quarter
representation knows how to turn it from
that source code into the final output
that you're creating
so overall you know very short slide but
just one that shows you how quick you
can get started with creating uh slide
decks with just a few lines of markdown
code
there's also this idea of incremental
lists and an incremental list means that
it increments across it so you might
have like three or four bullet points
and rather than displaying them all at
once you can actually have them be
incremental where it'll show bullet
point one then you click an arrow bullet
point two click the arrow bullet point
three and so on so that you can actually
walk through your slides like I'm doing
today as opposed to them all showing up
at one time
so you can do this from the yaml header
with incremental equals true
or you can turn it on and off via fence
divs so might have something like this
where again I use three uh colons to
start three colons to end and then I
have a DOT incremental class and this
will work across any of the presentation
formats and it'll say first Howard
sleeps and then the next one Howard
Sprints he's always sleeping or running
around in terms of he's he's an active
dog or he's a very sleepy dog
but you can walk through the different
parts of your presentation and control
the overall structure in this way
you can also turn off incremental so
let's say that you had incremental
equals true and you want to say that
well you know I want to say that Howard
eats and then he sleeps like that's kind
of one thought that I'm putting together
even though it's it's two different
bullet points so if he eats he's
immediately gonna go take a nap he's not
gonna go run around after that so you
can turn on or turn off these
incremental lists from the yaml or from
pandok uh fence divs with the dot
incremental or non-incremental classes
you can also control the overall
structure of your presentation in terms
of creating left and right columns or
how those appear
this one's a bit more complex in terms
you have what's called a DOT columns
class first and you might notice I have
four colons here at the start and four
colons at the bottom
this allows me to Nest additional uh
fence divs within that kind of parent
div
so overall I have a DOT columns class
and then I'm creating two or more
columns that I want to create within it
So within the dot columns class I create
another uh three colons with a DOT
column and I can control the width so
you know make it 50 50 or 40 60 or
whatever kind of percentage I want from
left and right
and then I'm also using reveal.js's dot
fragment class that allows me to display
the content on the left first and then
display the content on the right after
that's done
so you can kind of build off of these uh
classes and brackets and fence divs
together and overall structure your
document across different formats
foreign so while those type of things
are useful and that gets you a lot of
the way in terms of if I stopped right
there you could actually get started
making presentations like you could
actually make a nice presentation from
that I do want to call out some specific
reveal.js options that are very powerful
and allow you to do a lot of different
things
so I'm gonna have Rachel use one of our
secret tips so on this page we can use
alt plus click to zoom into a section
and if I pop up this tiny picture of
Howard on the screen she can all click
again to back out of that and she can
actually zoom in specifically on Howard
so you can imagine that you might have
source code or you know something else
on the page that looks small but you can
zoom in on it to highlight it
Rachel can also do command plus on her
screen that will actually increase the
size of things like the URL or the logo
at the bottom so she can zoom in a
little bit on the page and that will
actually make that a bit bigger and zoom
out a few times and make the URL a bit
smaller and overall just make that part
a little bit easier to work with
that's part of the benefit of HTML is
you can modify things temporarily on the
Fly
you can also use things called absolute
positioning so like that last image I
put it very specifically in the bottom
left so that we had to go find it and
zoom in on it
I use some code like this another fence
div and I use the dot absolute class and
then I can say what is the geometry so
from the bottom 25 pixels up and from
the left 100 pixels over and then
display the image as normally with a
fragment class which shows up later but
you can place it anywhere on the screen
in that way and really tightly control
placement of images or logos or even
text that you're putting on the page
that allows you to better tell stories
as you're moving through it
another one that I really like for
reveal.js is using what's called output
Dash location this is actually used
within code chunks so you might have
something like this where you're loading
the ggplot package doing a quick plot of
empty cars and then if I Advance the
slide it throws that image directly next
to it in the second column and it's a
fragment so it shows up later and this
again allows you to step through showing
the code and showing the output as
you're moving through the document
there are many other output Dash
location classes but just this is the
one that I find the most useful in terms
of delaying showing it and putting it in
the column next to the source code so I
can have long source code and a nice
image next to it
just like with HTML or using PDF with
different themes or kind of partials
you're bringing in
quarter presentations and specifically
reveal.js also come with built-in themes
so there's 10 themes listed here on the
page and you can apply those with the
theme argument in the yaml header and
again these will change all the
different elements of the presentation
uh including kind of the tables the
headers the background colors the
foreground colors lots of different
elements you can change on the Fly very
very quickly
if for some reason you didn't think the
theme was good enough or there was
something that you didn't agree with you
can always customize it further and
apply your own
custom.scss file to modify specific
components of the presentation
so like for today I wanted to use a very
specific font you know I like the fera
mono class of fonts for code and at our
studio we use open Sans as kind of our
default font family
so I can import those fonts from the
Google fonts API and then apply some
different colors make the text the
bottom orange make the level two headers
this nice dark blue kind of the star
studio blue and also use open Sans and
ferramano as my default font and my mono
space font
so again I you know not a lot of code
but just modifying a little bit to make
it look just like I wanted to so using a
theme and making it go farther with some
of these different customizations
I can also add a footer or specific logo
so I could use a local image so maybe I
have the rstudio logo locally at the
bottom right of my slide or I have some
footer that says like footer text or a
URL or another hyperlink to the source
code
for my presentations I like to again use
the URL to the hosted our studio logo so
I don't have to keep bringing it around
I can just link out to the URL of that
one and then for the footer I can also
use the uh you know a specific hyperlink
so with markdown style code I can say
reports and presentations recordo and
then link out to the slides that are
hosted on Porto Pub
but for this page you might notice the
footer is not that in terms of you can
actually change the footer as a one-off
and if you look at the very bottom it's
kind of small but did you see did you
notice the footer and using a fence div
you can apply a footer class and modify
the footer Slide by Slide by slide so
for one footer you might link out to
this URL and for the next one it could
be an entirely different footer you can
override the default that's defined in
the yaml
but again that will only apply for that
uh specific slide so if I Advance the
next one it'll go back to my overall URL
at this point you're probably seeing
dozens of pictures of Howard and his
nice gentleman outfit I've used what's
called a slide background to Overlay
many different images across that
not the most effective use of it but
just showing you a couple different
possibilities of how you can use images
or other things as your slide background
to tell a story
I did that with
um you know a level two header slide
background and then used these curly
brackets who actually define specific
things about it so made the color equals
black the background image was one of
Howard gentlemen and I made them 100
pixels wide and repeated if they were
not big enough to take up the whole
screen
overall there's a lot of different
things you can do with this in addition
to the background color you can use a
local or a URL to an image you can make
the image cover the background or not
cover make it a specific size change the
opacity or the transparency you can do a
lot of customization to really make it
easy to inject background images to your
slides
but you're not just limited to images
you can also use it with gifs if you're
using those to tell part of your story
or tell a joke
and you can even use it to just change
the color so I might do something like
slide background background color equals
black and this will make the overall uh
body black but make the text white it
will try and always do a high contrast
color for changing the font color itself
so you don't have to do that manually
you can just change the background color
and the foreground color will change
along with it
and just like with images or gifs you
can also do background videos these are
rather than background image it would be
background Dash video and you can
control the looping or does it play
audio or is it muted and again things
like the size or the opacity so you
could actually embed a full size video
taking up the entire screen if that was
what you were trying to do in your
slides or in your presentation
there are some other helpers so things
like R Dash stack and combining that
with fragments I can take three images
and display them on top of each other
very efficiently
um one by one by one
again you might have like several
different images in unison that you're
displaying so something like here's a
Boston Terrier in a field here's a
juvenile boss interior laying down on
the ground and here's an adult Boston
Terrier wearing fancy clothing and you
can all kind of stack them on top of
each other and apply them one by one by
combining the dot R stack and the
fragment classes to display them overall
as we close out we've got a couple more
slides to go I just want to again call
out Emil's article and kind of how we
approached using color and custom styles
to apply and change his documents
I hyperlinked out to his article so that
orange article will actually take you to
his overall blog post
but in his scss styles that he added he
included a DOT blue and a DOT yellow
class and these just inject a little bit
of color to help tell his story a little
bit differently in his presentations
so in action he might write some text
that looks like this he uses bracketed
spans to say Cordo in blue enables you
to weave together content which will
show up in yellow and executable code in
yellow into a finished presentation
to learn more about Cordo makes it blue
again
see this specific link
so by doing that he's using the existing
kind of context of bracketed spans but
adding in his own custom classes to
style the document a little bit
differently
and he gets a nice looking page like
this where you can really highlight that
quarto content executable code and
finish presentation is the story here so
while he might read off the slide or I
might read off this slide you can really
see that we're focused on Porto content
executable code and that's a nice
summary of what quarto provides content
text and executable code all together
and you can further extend this with
what you need to do or what you want to
do with writing your own classes
again he used the bracketed span syntax
so you know square brackets around some
text and then applying his specific
class to that but you can also use our
Studio's visual editor and he actually
talks about this in his article and you
can use you know insert a specific span
or specific div and then it'll pop up
saying what are the type of classes you
want to apply to that so this is really
useful for maybe you can't remember all
the different syntax you can actually
insert divs and spans with the visual
editor inside our studio
foreign
that's it for today we we got it all
done in an hour somehow we covered a lot
of different things with reports and
presentations theming them including
HTML PDF doing reports and presentations
together and separately parameterized
our markdown and parameterized quarto
and how those are different and the same
and I wanted to give you a few links out
to some nice articles and content
so if you just want to read about quarto
you can go to quarto.org docslash guide
that's the overall guide for Cordo but
there's also sub links to documents or
articles and reports or Journal articles
if you're trying to publish in an
academic setting
I also wanted to call out again a few of
the open source efforts by other people
outside of kind of the core quarto team
so quarto title Pages by the group from
nmfs or Emil and Megan's articles on
slidecraft 101 and quarto slides and
what those look like so a lot of nice
content here and you can access my
slides at Thomas
mock.cordo.pub slash reports Dash
presentations
or uh Rachel was kind enough to give me
a short link which is much better
rstd.io slash quarto Dash reports that
has all the content for today
I thought that might be a little easier
there thank you so much Tom really
really appreciate it this is awesome I'm
just getting started with Cordo too and
this is really helpful thinking about
some of the formatting I was trying to
figure out
uh there are so many great questions
um how long do we have before
I I'm here for the the full Journey so I
blocked off the remaining part of this
before lunch so I'm in for the Long Haul
awesome great so thank you all for for
all the great questions I did want to
remind everybody that you can ask
questions in LinkedIn if you're watching
there on YouTube live or you can ask
anonymously
um and I will show that slido here as
well I was also playing around with a
few polls as well so just asking if
people have used Cordo and what other
journals you would like to see so Tom if
there's other questions you want us to
ask everybody else feel free to put them
in the private chat
um but one of the let's go we'll go back
and forth between uh
YouTube and Linkedin here
a question from Jimmy was any plans to
make quarto template functionality
uh similar to what our markdown draft
does
if I'm being honest I'm not very
familiar with our markdown draft so give
me uh 10 seconds and I'll look up that
function but just very honestly I'm not
very familiar with the r markdown draft
option
um so let me make sure I understand the
question
and we'll go from there so let's see
ah okay so kind of like using it as a
template is my understanding is our
markdown draft uh creates and obviously
edits a draft of an R markdown based on
a template
so there's a couple ways of doing that
in terms of uh the rstudio dev team is
working on some more integration of like
there are our markdown templates that
exist in our studio and that's a kind of
a first class idea of you can like new
file new or markdown use the specific
template
a dark Studio Dev team is still working
on that idea for Cordo and then for
um quarter documents themself you can
use either the extensions kind of
workflow or kind of other ways of
bringing in kind of a overall document
importing code or specific chunks and
then further modifying it that's a good
option and I'll go back to the dev team
and see if we have some additional
thoughts there but um yeah cool cool to
learn about the draft function and kind
of learn something new on these
presentations
thank you a question from slido was can
you apply the same code highlighting to
different outputs so for example HTML or
PDF without the call having to be nested
under format
yeah so I would say the if you're doing
something like styling
um you're typically you're you're taking
that step forward saying the defaults
aren't good enough and I have very
strong opinions
um so I would say the safest option is
doing them separately because like PDF
has certain things it can do and HTML is
certain other things that it can only do
um so while there are times where you
can reuse the components like even when
I was using
[Music]
um
The Blood Theme which is kind of like a
Dracula style theme for presentations I
rendered it to PowerPoint and some of
the theming came across basically what
changes it could make but overall it
wasn't one to one per se so if you
really want to go further and customize
it like there's first class ways of
doing that in all the different formats
so PowerPoint you can import a a
template from PowerPoint PDF you can do
additional theming or Tech partials and
for HTML you can do CSS or scss to
customize them
so while yes you know for code
highlighting alone there are some
options where you can try and reuse it
there might be a time where you get
frustrated and it's better to kind of
hop out to if you're really trying to do
like PDF and make it look a certain way
further customizing it in that way
awesome thank you
um I was trying to go over to
let's see trying to go over to LinkedIn
for one of the answers to this question
so I will
ask a different one first oh wait here
it is Daniel asked any websites that in
your opinion have the best uh shiny
Cordo output examples that you could
share with others at your company
yeah I would say you know today what
quarto provides with integrating with
shiny is traditional websites in terms
of there's not a dashboard style chordo
yet that the quarto team is actively
working on dashboard style documents or
dashboard layouts with Cordo that that
will come in the future
um but you know if you're really trying
to invest in like shiny and trying to
make it look really beautiful with shiny
alone uh there's things like shiny
dashboard or fresh or BS lib specific to
shiny that allow you to structure and
and kind of theme those overall
documents
in the future we'll have kind of a
better answer for you which is like if
you're trying to create a dashboard with
shiny and Cordo together
um there will be a first class dashboard
format
however if you're creating it today it's
it's basically going to look like a
website that has shiny code built into
it so I would you know go to the
cordo.org there's a gallery
and that has a lot of the content today
and will be updated over time
um and I'll drop that chat link to
Rachel so she has the gallery link
um but you know today it talks about
like interactive docs with shiny or with
observable or Jupiter widgets
um but you know they're really going to
look like websites as opposed to
dashboards right now
awesome thank you yeah I put that link
into the chat I also see someone had
shared it on LinkedIn a bit earlier too
so thank you for sharing that
um someone else asked
um are there built-in themes for
PowerPoint
yeah so you know again some of the theme
components work
um across format so like I was using
like the The Blood Theme that's built in
for reveal.js and some of that came
across in the PowerPoint
um there is an article on quarter.org
for
um PowerPoint presentations specifically
and again once you get into the level of
theming that basically says like not
only do I care about outputting to
PowerPoint but someone has strong
opinions about that theme
um so if you use what are called
PowerPoint templates that's a first
class idea in the PowerPoint World both
in and outside of Cordo that is how you
can use like a company theme that
modifies the title page and the layout
and the colors and the fonts for
PowerPoint specifically and because
that's a proprietary format there are
some limitations around how much we can
do that in Cordo as opposed to how much
of that is like this solved answer is
use a template that that PowerPoint has
I really am I'm really impressed by
Tom's ability to talk and find The Links
at the same exact time and send them to
me so I just put that in the chat as
well
thanks Rachel
another one was how do you keep long
quarto documents organized for yourself
as you're working on a presentation
yeah there's a couple ways if I'm being
honest about like writing a presentation
I'm usually have many different things
open in terms of like I have some
experimentation files that I'm like
testing out specific ideas and then I'm
putting those into the individual slides
but I will say that in terms of like
when I write quarto documents in our
studio the level two headers the code
chunks all of those show up in the
document outline
um so if if you use that you can
navigate pretty quickly even through
like a 800 or 900 line presentation so
like today's one because it's almost 60
slides I want to say it was around like
700 lines of text overall
um and using the outline view in our
studio allows me to kind of move between
slides really quickly especially if I'm
like changing something at the title at
the very first slide and then jumping to
slide 50 like using those allows me to
navigate the document a bit better
the other thing I will just mention is
that Cordo
um regardless of the format does allow
you to use what are called includes so
you can imagine that the final document
I'm putting together for leadership
might actually be from four or five
different people and they might actually
write a specific section and then you
could just import or what is called
include them in the parent document
so if you look for includes on
quarto.org it will actually allow you to
access existing content and bring it
into the parent document and actually
just inject like all of that qmb or that
markdown file in that location
so especially if you have like a bunch
of different people working on one thing
yes you could collaborate across Source
control but they could also write their
own kind of thing and you just bring it
into the parent
great thank you
um okay this is a little bit of a longer
question
um so essentially like what are the
benefits of converting from our markdown
to Cordo especially for someone who
maybe has hundreds of of our markdown
reports yeah
I would say overall the the beauty is
that we support both in terms of if I
say we as in our studio like the core
team that works on our markdown is the
same team that works on Cordo so you
don't have to change everything which is
a great thing like if someone told you
tomorrow hey stop doing what you're
doing and move to this that would be
very disruptive and that's not the goal
of anything with Cordo there are
differences and there are trade-offs and
benefits for using Cordo or using our
markdown for certain situations but
especially if you've got like a thousand
line our markdown report or you've got a
workflow that's working great like keep
using it like we're continuing to
support our markdown we're not like
abandoning it we are still doing bug
fixes and kind of improvements over time
just if you think about it with like new
features there were limitations in terms
of how we extended our markdown the way
to extend our markdown was to write
another r package that extended it and
with quarto a lot of it is baked into
the one in install so rather than having
to manage multiple packages or have it
be only with r we're trying to not only
improve things for our our users but
also bring essentially like all of our
markdown to the Julia language into
Python and to teams that don't even use
code like just bring a visual editor and
markdown style scientific communication
without having to manage data science
languages so it's a bit hard of a
question to answer in a short format but
I would say just like if you have
existing our markdown you can keep using
them for basic our markdown you can use
quarto to actually render or convert
those but you definitely don't have to
convert over
and would for somebody
hoping to convert some of their docs is
that welcome to Cordo Workshop a good
resource or what would you yes
yeah that first uh overview as well as
some of the content on quarto.org it
talks about uh taking an existing arm
markdown and a basic one at that where
the conversion cost is essentially zero
because Cordo and our markdown are
essentially backwards compatible with
each other
the difference being that like our
markdown has specific CSS and PDF and
latex that it applies and Cordo does
things a little bit different visually
like the the code will still work
between them for the most part but the
visual representation is different
between the two
okay yeah the two-hour webinar had some
some additional content that would go
over that
awesome
um I see a question from Rob on LinkedIn
that was would things like check boxes
or radio buttons be available or would
one need shiny for that level of
complexity
there's a couple ways to approach it
um so yes if you want check boxes and
radio buttons that execute our code then
you would need shiny right because you
have to have a server that takes that
checkbox you're doing and executes it
along with some R code
however
um both an r in Python and in JavaScript
within Cordo there are things for check
boxes or cross language talking so in R
there's things called HTML widgets and
crosstalk that provides basic filters
and select with check boxes and little
buttons
in Python there's something called
IPython Widgets or IPI widgets that
again give you both a JavaScript kind of
framework and then some some toggles you
can do with it
or native to kind of the JavaScript land
but also applies to other languages
observable.javascript is included with
Cordo so you can build out custom kind
of interfaces and check boxes
um you know just through Court of alone
that interact with both R and python
code
so I'll drop a link to Rachel for
observable JavaScript that's going to
look very similar to shiny in terms of
like the the buttons you're expecting
um and it can be embedded with r and
with shiny and with python but it's
actually JavaScript that you're writing
just in a very friendly way like it's a
great library and I'm glad it was
included with uh the integration
recorder
great thank you heading back over to
slido some of the questions over there
any plans to add more categories to the
author argument and the yaml
because it's well known you can add
authors and affiliations but it would be
cool to also add role
yeah absolutely so the the default
things that are available from Cordo are
kind of limited to what's available for
like the categories in the author
especially once you get into specific
Journal formats the authors section and
affiliations really expand because
certain articles and certain journals
want new things added on like there are
requirements so
um yes some of the journal articles that
already exist those Journal article
extensions allow for this and if you're
interested you can also add your own
format that adds whatever you want like
you could add a favorite pet as an
author argument to your yaml and just
like write an extension that provides
that
um if you wanted to learn more about
that I would look at the kind of article
templates
um that you can modify on quarto.org and
those are kind of like dot Tech formats
or css that you're bringing in that
allow you to further extend what's
available in the ammo header and that's
really what those extensions are for is
adding on custom things that you want to
see that maybe aren't as generally used
awesome thank you and I see you had
shared with me Tom a question for
everybody and it was what kind of chordo
content would you like to see in the
future and so I just put that as a poll
over on the slido as well if you want to
share there
awesome okay I see someone just asked a
question over on LinkedIn and it is
mayank asked can we include custom HTML
CSS JavaScript code combination for
parts of a quarter document as we did
with our markdown
yeah absolutely so there's option when I
talked about includes from before that
include could be used for including
child documents or other qmds but I also
just dropped a link for Rachel called
includes you know before body after body
in header resources metadata files those
different options allow you to include
like literal JavaScript code or css or
like Google Google analytics dot HTML
files that are injected into the
document and those are able to be
included in a couple of the most common
locations so before the body after the
body in the header like there's specific
locations where HTML needs to inject
that type of metadata for it to be used
by the website so Cordo has a first
class support for doing that with the
include Dash something else options
great thank you
um Arun asked on YouTube does Cordo work
with a Sharingan
yeah so
um it there's a long answer and a short
answer and I'll try and do both quickly
so the uh the long answer is that
Sharingan uses a library called
remark.js which is not pandok compatible
markdown so while it was useful with our
markdown it's funny like Yi Wei was
actually talking about it he never
intended for it to be popular it was for
his use
um and it required what he called like
Ninja level knowledge to to do certain
things with it
um reveal.js is pandok compatible
markdown so that's the one that that
Cordo settled on as the HTML format is
that because you could use it with the
visual editor and it was compatible with
all the rest of pandok
um that was the one that they they
settled on
if you take an existing Sharingan
presentation uh and try and render with
quarto it will work in terms of on
putting that in scare quotes
um it will render it into some type of
presentation but Sharingan used a lot of
custom themes a lot of custom CSS custom
classes and different ways of writing
that is just not fully compatible with
quarto
that all being said and continuing the
long answer I was a Sharingan absolute
power user loved using it and I've fully
converted over to doing reveal.js that I
really really enjoy it I if you know if
I wanted to I could still write
Sharingan but reveal.js adds in a lot of
things that clicked with me and again
the unified syntax across all of HTML is
nice where I don't have to remember how
do I do it in this one specific package
but this is the way to do it across all
HTML style outputs in quarto was nice
option
thank you quick reminder if anybody's
looking for the content and slides from
The Talk today I'll just share the link
up here on the screen again
um I see a few slider questions that I
have a lot of upvotes right now and one
is any plans of creating tutorials
um for DOT I don't think I know what
this is but dot TX templates for PDF
output for Cordo would be amazing
yeah so there's some ongoing work for uh
writing things like Lua filters
um and other things like that
um let me see if I can find the Lua
development in creating formats
so this article I'm sharing with Rachel
has some of the information about like
when you're writing a custom format what
all do you need to include
um ultimately in terms of like while we
might end up writing like dot Tech uh
template examples or theming components
Tech is its own massive ecosystem and
while you might be able to get
introduced to it from
quarto.org for example it's such a broad
topic that I'd be afraid that lots of
things would get left out
so multiply it's like if your team you
know what cordo's trying to provide is a
lot of very common and Powerful
templates so things like Journal
articles where I could publish to this
journal without knowing any Tech right
like that that is my mindset I don't
know any latex and I can still publish
in the format that this journal wants so
jss wants this you know latex file that
they're getting I can do that with Cordo
if I want to customize PDF to go a
certain way I really need to learn a
little bit of tech or Tech partials uh
to to further customize that and that's
a skill that I would need to develop to
be successful in that role
um so yes and no in terms of there's
some documentation around creating
formats and how that can be used for
specific things and distributing them
developing filters and things with Lua
but there aren't major plans for for
Tech templates today
again I do want to call out that like uh
the open source Community has already
started building out some of these so
I'll call it again this group and
they're in the gallery on quarter.org
they actually put together
um source code for for kind of how
they've approached building out those so
grabbing that content in FMS
Cordo pandok I'm actually looking for
this one so give me a second to find
those I could go back to my presentation
and just do it that way
there we go all right so I'm going to
drop this into the chat for Rachel so
that one actually talks about how to
modify their templates and how to modify
and use and DIY some of it that resource
is amazing like it's a great amount of
work they did to both do it but then
also write about how they did it so
while that won't teach you everything
about dot Tech and partials and
everything else it at least gives you
like a nice structured way of learning
and again because it's an open source
project over time additional people
including us and others will build out
educational content or kind of extension
content around that
so specifically the how to use DIY and
how to modify on that link that Rachel
just shared and if you wanted to
actually screen share that page
um that I can walk you through some of
that on the side it's a it's a great
site and kudos to that team
awesome let me get that up I was just
trying to uh copy over to LinkedIn too
and just let everybody know if you're
looking for these real-time links and
you're watching on LinkedIn I wasn't
able to do both at the same time so if
you want to head over to YouTube
but uh here let me put this
up yeah so again this page has like
seven or eight templates that they
provide that are great like they just
work out of the box but off of the left
side bar if you see the how to use DIY
or how to modify those actually if you
click on like how to modify
um it talks about you know the first
thing modifying pandok template sounds
like fun like yes it's kind of uh
tongue-in-cheek but you know you can
modify it how it works what is going on
and it talks a little bit about like
what the things you do for quarto as
well as like some of the things you use
for their specific format but again
because there's so much customization
you can do in the dot Tech file that's
completely separate from Cordo
um you do at some point have to learn
that if you really want to customize all
of that yourself
but this is a great starting page it
talks about the latex structure and all
sorts of other things I would go here
great great resource
awesome thank you
thank you okay uh let's go through as
many questions as we can get to and I
promise I will share all these other
questions with you Tom if we don't get
sounds a good thing okay
um
so if this is anonymous question if we
know we want to use a number of
parameters do we have to give one of
those parameters as a default in the
yaml
yeah so you'll want to Define them at
least because you could imagine that
when you're trying to render it if you
have a if you indicate it in the body of
the document it has to have a default
value
so if you don't Define it in the yaml
then when the document is just rendered
with like the render button or quarter
render
um it's going to fail because that
object doesn't exist and it's like I
don't know where to find this it doesn't
exist so you will need to Define at
least some default in the yaml that's
used for the first rendering and then
you can modify it further
that really applies to both like the
body of the document because you have to
write you know params dollar sign syntax
or or use in in Python you have to at
least like use that object and again if
it's not defined then python or R are
just not going to know what to do with
an object that's not defined
I love to see people are helping
answering each other answer each other's
questions on the slido as well
um but one of those I thought might be
helpful to just cover here too is yeah
how can we include the current date yeah
in the yaml file
you don't even have to use sys.date you
can do date equals today date colon
today uh one of my favorite uh someone
actually asked me about that this
morning just before coming on to the
presentation and it's one of my favorite
tricks because it's language agnostic so
again you don't have to uh you don't
have to do it
you know only within using sys.date but
on quarto dates and formatting there's a
built-in default for using date equals
today or date equals now or date equals
last dot modified so there's multiple
things you can do with it in terms of
like did you modify it today did you
modify with a specific time as well as
the date or when was the last time the
document was modified not rendered right
like those are all separate things and
if you just did sys.date it's not as
flexible as some of those things that
are just built in free options that are
awesome now and I I love those things
okay so Tom you just got really excited
about that one so I'm I'm curious dates
and tables are apparently my thing what
is your favorite thing that you've
learned in switching over to quarto
where you're like wow that was amazing
I think the biggest just like kind of
like mind blown like absolute new
feature for me was was freeze with
projects
um there's so many little bitty things
that are cool like date equals today and
unified syntax and listings but if I
were to identify one or two and I just
thought of two we'll stick with those
one is for projects
um freeze equals true which allows me to
store the computation for an entire
project like for my personal blog that's
five years old I can store the
computation from the first article I
wrote five years ago and I don't have to
re-render that one every time so that's
super powerful for collaboration or for
um just like managing documents over
time I dropped a link to Rachel for that
one
the other one that's kind of just like
mind-blowing is website listings
um because you can basically create
custom listings and build out like
summaries and cards and
um
little grid layouts of all this
different type of content manually or
from source files and just built very
nice looking Pages like just remarkably
complex in a good way
um
I have to link out to this and we're
going to screen share it so sorry one
more but this is the page that gets me
excited about custom listings and I just
drop that in the chat if you want to
screen share that connect widgets fake
one
about listings specifically
so the reason why I find this so cool is
like if you look at this page it's a
summary of a large end-to-end data
science task and we're hosting it on
like rstudio connect but in terms of
like there's all these different things
it's doing
so it provides this kind of background
of where you can say like here's the
diagram of all the things that are
occurring there's a quarter document
there's vetiver there's apis they're all
communicating together and as you
navigate down the page uh if you go
further to like schedule jobs and things
like that keep going
there's tabs and cards and other
different things that allow you to just
like move through all these assets
you've created like this data science
team put together 15 different things
that make up this complex robust data
science project and with listing Pages
you're actually able to aggregate these
into tables with filters and sorting and
cards and all that's natively built into
quarto as like a first class thing so
you don't have to escape out to
I've been trying to figure out this one
how do you do this I got source code for
that one the answer is lots of yaml but
let me grab I'll show you the GitHub
repo so we can share that out as well
because this is like the mind-blowing
one to me it's just like
all of that I'll drop one more link to
you Rachel here in the chat
so that is a public uh repository called
test Dash listing
and it goes through basically the idea
of building the connect widgets our
package only with quarto so you don't
have to use kind of the structure of
connect widgets but you can rebuild all
that formatting with cards and uh grid
and and tables so I really like this
that was like a motivating listings are
really cool you should try them out
that's amazing thank you okay
um I'll try to go through just a few
more questions I know yes we can't we
could stay on here all day but we can't
really so okay
[Music]
um
so going over to John's question on
YouTube
is there a Styler for Cordo like an R
Studio add-in
so
there's a package called BS lib that has
a first class plug-in for exploring
themes for our markdown
um I do imagine at some point BS lib
theming will probably be available in
quarto but it's not today so my answer
is there is not a r Studio add-in as of
this moment in time that might change
over time
um boot Swatch theme picker I'm just
looking uh
uh I believe
okay there might be an option for just
like modifying boot Swatch in terms of
like those are the 25 themes that are
built in to Cordo there's probably an
application that hosts a boot Swatch
theme modifier because that's really
what's happening is bootstrap CSS boot
swatches the opinionated themes and you
can modify them
um
so no there's not but that's a good idea
and we're probably already working on it
great thank you
okay maybe we're having too much fun
with the polls over here but I just
wanted to ask one more over there
um and it doesn't have to be related to
quarto but I was just wondering for
people listening in what is a challenge
that you've faced in the past few weeks
that we could explore creating content
for
and it doesn't have to be like code
specific or or Cordo it could even be
about like people focus or organization
um but just wanted to ask that everybody
to everybody as we think about what
would be most helpful for you all
um and that's just on the
the slido you can access the poll there
okay
uh one other question from slido
can you please quickly throw light on
how to publish a quarter document to
Cordo pub with the yaml attributes
setting file
hear more attributes I'm
assuming I don't want to assume too much
let me make sure uh
mammal attributes is kind of a loaded
term in terms of
we could ask for clarification yeah
um if you want to clarify in that one so
quarto Pub I would say the the best
resource is that like
Porto Pub is is a first class kind of
description with the documentation on
quarto.org and it has a published.yaml
uh example I think that's probably what
you're talking about in terms of that's
a yaml file that allows you to modify
settings for a specific quarter Pub
um you could include that around the
context of like your existing project
for most people
um the way that you would use quarto
publish or quarto pubs is you would from
the terminal you would do quarto publish
quarto Dash Pub and then the file you
want to publish and it will then walk
you through interactively the process of
like selecting your credentials and yes
you want to name it this and Publishing
that
with a quarto pub and the underscore
published at yaml or if you're doing
that non-interactively with something
like continuous integration or GitHub
actions or Azure devops or our studio
connect
um you can go further and basically like
write some of those ahead of time
because you aren't going to be there to
to do those steps
that's a again a pretty big thing to
think about so there's a lot there's
like a whole section on publishing on
quarto.org that's fairly new so maybe
last time you were looking it wasn't
there but it has like description of the
underscore published ieml the publish
command as well as the non-interactive
publishing with continuous integration
um and I think I yeah I shared that with
Rachel and she'll show that in the chat
foreign
okay a few other questions one from
slido is there a comprehensive quarto
cheat sheet or web page
they clarified and said I'm finding bits
and pieces of code for the yaml header
and code chunks but nothing
comprehensive
so the best option if you it's not it's
not a cheat sheet at all but I would
consider it more of like a reference or
an appendix so if you go to quarto.org
docs slash reference or at the top
quarter.org there's a reference header
yeah okay perfect
um and then at the top it says reference
that fourth item okay
this provides for all the formats and
different things you can do what is
possible so these are this is not
expanding on it in great detail it's
just describing it but let's say for
yaml header if you click on documents
the HTML the first one uh there
these are all the yaml options you can
provide and then they're structured by
what is like the grouping
so this is pretty Bare Bones but it like
tells you what's possible and what does
it actually mean
this is also duplicated so when you're
writing quarto documents in our studio
or in vs code with the quarto extension
if you do Control Plus space inside the
yaml header it will basically pull up
this list and you can start filtering it
so you could say like you know start
typing title and it will say like title
is something you can auto complete and
describing it as the document title but
this reference section gives you a
massive amount of just I want the
highlights or the cheat sheet of like
all the different uh things that are
possible and then if you want to go into
like how would I actually use them
that's where the guide section would be
more useful
okay and that was Control Plus space
yep Control Plus space inside the yaml
header or inside a Hash Pipe in the code
chunk will basically like pull up a
search bar essentially of like what load
is possible that you can do inside our
studio
great thank you
I think there are a few questions that
touch upon this
um to to math and apologies if I
mispronounce your name ask is there
going to be a quarto dashboard offering
similar to flex dashboard
yes there will be in the future coming
soon TBD
okay great let's okay two more questions
I promise cool
okay let me just double check on slido
the most that we answered the most
upvoted ones too
okay another uh yaml question for you
one was the yaml file option for quarto
CLI
um to set parameters was not mentioned
any reason
yeah so uh execute params is a sub
command there for
if you think of a qmd and I'm kind of
thinking that as like the first thing
that I'm working on is like a doc UMD
file
um in that context every time you
execute the document
it executes it from top to bottom
linearly and re-executes everything
for Jupiter notebooks using like python
for example a jupyter notebook can be
rendered with the stored execution
because a jupyter notebook behind the
scenes is actually a DOT Json file that
actually stores the computation that
when it was executed
um so you can either do that and use
whatever the parameters were that were
in the document as is the defaults or if
we use dash dash execute Dash params the
one that uh the question has been asked
about that will basically like force an
execution or reference an external file
in some cases like maybe you don't
um you can imagine like writing out dash
param one dash param two dash param 3
Dash param four like continuing on and
through the CLI is a lot of typing so if
you use like a a
external params.yaml file that will
simplify uh the writing of it because
you have like a file that has all those
different parameters defined that you're
bringing in
great thank you okay
um
one other question that was asked on I
think YouTube
shoot just lost it okay how do you
install Cordo extensions
yep so from the uh there's two options
for quarter extensions
um are text files or or zip files so you
can literally download it and copy and
paste it over like I just want to say
like that's totally possible but
um if you look at the extensions uh page
on quarto.org it actually walks through
how to install extensions so from the
quarto command line interface you could
do like quarto install extension font
awesome or quarto install extension
quarter extension uh video or lightbox
and it will install that extension into
a folder in your project
um so the quarto command line interface
is the correct way to do that but I just
want to note that they are literally
text files so you can download it and
like copy it or move it around between
folders if you wanted to just the quarto
command line interface provides a
a helper function to do that efficiently
great thank you I realized I just threw
42 minutes of questions at you so
really appreciate it Tom thank you for
an awesome talk as well one last
question it if people are looking for
like the best way to stay up to date on
new quarto features or where to go and
how to like get in touch with the Cordo
team what's the best way to do that
so if I were to say stay up to date
um quarto has a news let me see if
there's the
getting started
all right so on the download page if you
want to open this up
um
and screen share that one
um
so if you wanted to get to there and
we'll start from the beginning if you
click on get started at the top of
quarto
and you see it has the default it says
like Linux Mac Windows you can install
if you see that release notes and more
downloads below windows and the table
uh yep
if you click on that it'll take you to
the download page and then if you scroll
down it'll say here's all the things
that have happened in the latest version
so you can see that the team's doing a
lot of really cool work and adding a lot
of things
that's in the current released version
and if you scroll back up it also links
out to the um kind of pre-release next
version the alpha that's coming out in
the future and that also has uh release
notes at the bottom of the page that
we'll talk about like what's coming down
the pipeline or what are they working on
um
ultimately like because certain things
released quickly just like that page is
going to be the best uh
broad overview of what's coming and
what's happening
um but if you do have questions in terms
of like that's a a pull kind of thing
like I just want to read about what's
happening great I can go there if you're
running into trouble or if you have
questions for the dev team at the top of
that page under help
it says ask a question
that button will take you to uh the
quarto dev GitHub discussions and there
you can ask specific questions and the
team can assist or the best thing to do
is to search for your question there
I guarantee that for a lot of things
other people have asked questions about
your topic and you might actually be
able to find the answer there before we
can put it into like documentation form
or into a new feature
so you can search for all sorts of
different things and say like hey
there's weird Behavior or I'm not quite
understanding and someone may have
already asked that question or the the
dev team might have answered that
question or said oh this is a problem
we'll we'll turn it into a GitHub issue
for example
that's cool I didn't I didn't realize
that was right from the court of sight
too yeah
cool the short answer to everything is
quarto.org
has all of your answers or will send you
to the place to ask more questions
perfect
thank you so much Tom really really
appreciate it just want to let everybody
know that this recording is available
immediately after the talk ends it's
just at the same YouTube live link and I
will try and go through probably not
within the next hour or so but I'm gonna
go grab all those links that Tom shared
and put them with the recording as well
but you should be able to see them in
the chat too
but thank you everybody thanks so much
for staying and hanging out with us as
well have a great rest of the day
thanks everybody thanks Rachel